bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va se
faire une petite vidéo spéciale test du
samsung galaxy à 8 j'en profite d'un
petit week end à la neige pour tester et
si les conditions sont activés renard et
la neige de partout le spot super c'est
super beau
[Musique]
pour
je teste tout de suite sur la caméra
avons à faire plusieurs choses switch
caméra avant caméra arrière pour faire
plein de plans différents
la seule chose que je m'autorise dans
cette vidéo c'est un petit stabilisateur
parce que je marche je me déplace du
coup pour m que ce soit c'est ce mot si
c'est parce moussa va rapidement être la
merde mais là vous allez voir c'est
hyper cool ça me travaille sur l'étrave
in de dagne surtout je trouve que le
stabilisateur de star ac 6 à 8 pour la
caméra arrière
il est pas mal mais il est pas génial on
pourrait faire beaucoup beaucoup mieux
donc bon ça bouge un petit peu ça fait
quand même son petit effet ça rend quand
même service mais sait pas où c'est pas
officines par contre point de vue
qualité c'est pas mal on filme en full
hd par derrière 1920 par 1080 pareil à
l'avant pas de katia si vous en voyez
folle et sera ensuite voir seront à neuf
où l'on reçoit nos smartphones on va
regarder ça plus en détails et pour
l'instant je vais vous montrer plein de
plans de ouf
plein de choses de ouf à la neige comme
ça on va tester les caméras alors si
c'est cool l'aise dos
l'été
des notes
ouais
oui
tous
au sort
compeyre
ça
soumis à toutes
oui
raymond
[Musique]
est-ce qu'on n'a pas trop mal bossé je
vous présente égard le bonhomme de neige
[Musique]
voici les jeux t'avoir garde contre tout
rires c'est trop facile
spot est juste ou faux ce retrait le
film n'a que les caméras avant la de
galaxies 8
le rush triste un peu en train de filmer
avec un guide bol pour stabiliser parce
que sinon c'est compliqué ça me permet
d'avoir un peu plus de recul
c'est super joli sigle ouf et là
regardez là la cascade 2 août
[Musique]
ça
m
bon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il est bon samsung a lui eu lieu rien
ball au final verdict de ce samsung
galaxy à huit mois je trouve plutôt pas
mal je trouve qu'il est bien pour faire
des vidéos et des photos que ce soit la
caméra avant d'ailleurs la double caméra
vent ou la caméra arrière
le rendu est super bien lâché dans une
pièce s'est pas particulièrement
lumineux par contre le rendu à la vidéo
est super lumineux et je trouve ça
vraiment bien alors c'est sûr que
lorsque vous filmez et qui a une belle
luminosité extérieure comme sur la vidéo
je vous ai montré tout de suite le rendu
est beaucoup plus beau et même par
faible luminosité ça marche super bien
et c'est en ça serait 8 est vraiment
bien pour la photo et pour la vidéo
j'ai fait aussi quelques clichés je puis
vous assurer qu'en terme de photos je le
trouve vraiment pas mal ressemblent à
des modifications au niveau de la
colorimétrie j'ai juste fait quelques
réglages sur ce soir un peu plus punchy
mais dans l'ensemble ça va plutôt pas
mal d'ailleurs je sais pas si vous
l'avez déjà essayé ce smartphone si vous
avez d'autres produits chez samsung
et est ce que vous êtes satisfait du
rendu photo et vidéo mark et moi tout ça
en commentaire je vous invite comme
d'habitude à rester connectés parce
qu'on va parler toujours plus de high
tech deux produits technologiques je
vais prendre d'ici quelques jours le
galaxy s 9 en main au mwc
donc restez connectés y avoir plein de
produits plein de nouveautés j'ai plein
plein de choses de prévues vous allez
voir on va se régaler je remercie
beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette vidéo je
vous invite comme d'habitude à vous
abonner à rester connectés a blessé des
jurys pouces vous embrasse soyez sages
et d'ici là portez vous bien
ciao